this is the story of the worst
influencer scam i've
ever seen and i've seen a lot of them
okay i'm practically a connoisseur at
this point
a specialist in influencer scams if you
will so believe me
when i tell you that so today i'm going
to be giving you the short version and
then the full
juicy story of the new allegations
coming out on quote
save the kids token we already know that
save the kids was a failed crypto pushed
by some of the top
influencers on youtube if you haven't
already seen my video
it's right here you can also watch
mudahar's video on this we've covered
this in great detail but what
no one knows is whether any of these
influencers knew it was going to be a
scam
ahead of time they can and have claimed
plausible deniability one of them saying
quote i have no
ill intent promoting any crypto altcoins
it was all a big mistake they are
victims just like the other people
today i will be showing that this was a
complete lie
because i've traced some of these
influencers crypto wallets
and will be revealing what they did with
the crypto coins
they've promoted to you and are now
trying to
hide the evidence now that it's all
coming out i will also be showing you
hard proof that this save the kids token
wasn't designed to benefit
kids i will show you in the literal code
of the coin
itself that it was designed from the
outset
with the intention to extract money from
these influencers fans
and followers let's get started ladies
and gentlemen welcome to the 10
million dollar studio i'm your host
coffeezilla the internet detective
and wow there's no way to make this a
short story
so we're going to start this case at the
beginning a month ago a friend of mine
reached out to me and told me about a
failed crypto project
called save the kids token that wasn't
that surprising i get
tips all the time and i just sort of
shelved the project while working on my
tether investigation
but something they had said had stuck
with me they had told me that several
huge influencers were on board with this
one making it different
face k face jarvis face tico face nikken
rice gum summer rae i mean these are
some big names here some of the biggest
in the influencer world together they
have well over
50 million followers between them so the
fact that all these huge names are
behind something
it made me want to revisit it how could
they allow themselves to promote
something that fell
so flat as soon as it launched it was
dead on arrival
you know this got me interested and it
had me thinking i had recently covered
the kim kardashian promotion i'd seen
the floyd promote crypto and i was
starting to wonder
how much money is actually involved in
this stuff
right how much are people paid to do
this
i mean i'm sure these influencers love
kids as much as the next guy
but you're not going to do a commercial
like this for free
my name's frasier my name is jarvis i'm
tico i'm ricegum i'm nikon
and i support save the kids token save
the kids token
save the kids token save the kids token
save the kids token so
i decided to look into it the first
thing i did was go to their post mortem
on save the kids uh hack md
article they wrote some article
basically explaining why it all failed
they said in a post the most important
thing to state here
is that ambassadors of save the kids are
not paid by us
and are not given any kids tokens
ambassadors didn't delete tweets and
then dump their tokens as claimed in the
telegram
as ambassadors were never given any
tokens any of our ambassadors are
involved in our project
because they have bought into and
believe in our mission ah yes we'll
come back to that later they believe in
helping kids remember that
so i'm thinking at this point okay they
believe in their project you're saying
they weren't given any kids tokens
didn't delete any tweets so why'd the
project fail additionally i read about
something called the anti-whale anti-bot
mechanism
this is essentially a piece of hard code
that prevents
large holders of a coin from selling out
at once
and this piece of marketing was repeated
over and over again
anti-whale measures can't sell more than
0.1 percent or transfer it in 24 hours
no larger than 20 of a whale's bodied
wallet
can be sold within 24 hours yes and the
whole idea here is to show people that
this project is not going to be a quick
rug pull which in crypto is a term for
when a project gets pumped and dumped
immediately on arrival and is abandoned
by large investors and in their
post-mortem they say
these actual measures did indeed work as
expected
it was audited by tech rate but if
everything worked as expected
and these ambassadors were just in it
for the kids
why did the project immediately crash
was it an
accident i decided to investigate their
telegram to learn more and i quickly
realized
the actual members were telling a very
different story
members of the telegram were panicking
and insisting that
millions were scammed phased team took
the profit and left
why would faze risk their reputation for
this you guys do know
faze clan has done multiple pump and
dumps right lmao there's a reason
all their tweets were removed after they
sold out on launch and usually you don't
have a whole host of people
accusing you of scamming if there was
nothing fishy going around
so i decided to do some further digging
and this whole idea of ambassadors
and not being given any coins turns out
to maybe be wrong
according to the admin they said
ambassadors bought in
we don't have their wallets don't know
who bought or sold
interesting because earlier we were told
they didn't sell and then we get
this news we got confirmation from some
of our ambassadors that they would not
sell anything and simply
bought pre-sale to support the project
if you don't know
pre-sell is a special access to people
before
the token becomes publicly available on
the market typically
you get much better rates to buy at but
again this idea that these influencers
didn't get anything from this project
other than just wanting to help the kids
seems to be a little bit disingenuous
since it seems like some of them
bought in but again we're reassured look
they're not they're not gonna sell
right so at this point i'm thinking
things are really fishy so i reach out
to lucas
the developer see after the failure of
save the kids and everything flopped
he was basically the last person still
hanging around the project
and at first he seemed helpless kind of
like a fall guy honestly
in a post a moderator explains that
lucas
is not the founder of this coin even
though he developed it he says quote
lucas is a dev that was contracted till
the 14th of june to write and set the
foundation of this coin
lucas chose to stay on and to work on
this project on his own accord
whilst the others left and he's not the
owner of the coin
fair enough a little bit weird that we
don't know who's responsible for this
giant coin that's pushed by these huge
celebrities but
fine when i reached out lucas responded
and was pretty eager to help honestly he
had said he had been taking a break from
telegram
i said no worries thanks for reaching
back out i asked him who is the true
founder of save the kids because he just
seems like a developer but it seems like
he would know
was it faze clan influencer the mob like
who's involved in this thing
i literally have no idea he told me i
wish i could let you know
because i really don't we kept talking
and he told me that he suspected
foul play and that this was bigger than
one crypto coin
my theory a group of large money names
are going around
finding dev teams finding promoters and
setting up
a large hyped launch then dipping
initially he also told me
the only real contact he had was to a
guy named
manny and h i asked for their contact
information
he said no clue blocked i got blocked by
all of the team basically
all right so at this point i'm pissed
right like
here's this poor dev who gets made to be
the fall guy for token
that like wasn't his idea he got seems
like he got hired to do it
now it's coming on him so i'm like look
can you think of
any tie to the founders you know it only
takes
one clue to find everything and he
responds that he does have a clue
so i got tokenomics gmail.com that sent
me the contract who i also
emailed back my paypal for the 10k they
paid me
then all the rest was from h on telegram
bingo that's all we need
tokenomics gmail.com that's the clue
that's going to unravel everything i
start searching the internet right
i get the computers running 24
7. it was all clocked in but i can't
find anything this account
is a ghost usually there are a few
threads you can pull on
nothing so then i contact my buddy
barely sociable he starts digging around
and pings me back
with news i couldn't have ever expected
the kid is lying
that email doesn't exist on paypal i
used forgot password to check
according to paypal there is no account
associated with that tokenomics
gmail.com that's something that i hadn't
considered before
maybe this developer if he's a real
person maybe he's lying to me
and he's actually involved in sending me
on some wild goose chase i i don't want
to let him know i'm suspicious yet
so i start asking for you know this
contract that he seems to have signed
all of a sudden he gets testy he asks
for a lawyer hmm
interesting the next day he makes it
even more clear
he says hey zilla sorry so my lawyer
said don't share anything for now
and also i'm not sure i'm willing to
help out much more since your video has
been
up i've gotten a lot of death threats
and somehow my family even got one so
i'm not looking to further involve
myself
sorry hope you understand just as a
quick caveat i didn't mention lucas
in the video at all that he's talking
about i respond lucas
you need to talk man if you have nothing
to hide i can make sure you get fairly
represented
but parts of your story aren't lining up
like this 10 000 from paypal
from tokenomics gmail.com i checked that
email for paypal
it doesn't exist a couple hours later he
deleted his account
all these logs were saved in advance and
at this point
i'm pissed because i'm pretty sure that
this kid is full of it or not
telling me the whole story of what he
knows
and is sort of trying to back out of
this thing because i never mentioned him
in my video and he's sort of all of a
sudden as soon as i start asking
bigger questions he starts clamming up
talking about lawyers
and i'm still no closer to finding out
the truth about what happened
with save the kids i mean was it
influencers what was it this developer
was it
this anonymous founder mr h like who's
behind it all
who's responsible for this in my first
video i'd put out i had called the coin
a scam
but there's not much you can say as far
as did they sell
didn't they it sure seems like they did
but we don't know
who or how much they sold so it feels
like at
every turn i'm stonewalled the dev isn't
talking i can't trace the wallets
the influencers are staying silent now
the thing is at this point we kind of
know
these influencers got in on the pre-sale
we were told as much but
here's the thing we know where those
pre-sales went that's one cool feature
of the blockchain technology it's public
to everyone you know
where the money was sent what those
wallets then did with those
save the kids tokens exactly when they
sold them if they bought more
et cetera it's all out there the problem
is we don't know whose wallets
are whose there isn't some big name on
these long blockchain
addresses that says like faze clan or
rice gum
it's just a bunch of random numbers and
letters and without that key information
there's no way of really telling which
influencers sold what
and if they were just dupes you know
maybe they got in over their heads and
simply were fooled like everyone else
maybe they were victims right so we
really don't have the full story
so for a day or two i was just like
stuck thinking about how can we prove
whose wallets are whose but then i
remember something
these influencers have been deleting
tweets like
a lot some of them deleted their support
of save the kids project
but that's not all they've even deleted
other crypto
projects that they've promoted and done
giveaways and i started to wonder
what if those projects were also scams
what if at minimum they were
equally sketchy what if this wasn't a
one-time thing and what if
they left some incriminating evidence in
one of their earlier schemes
it's worth a shot because like my other
leads were drying up quick
so i just start no lifeing the archives
tweet after deleted tweet i'm hunting
through and finally i notice a pattern
of giveaways with some of these guys
they'll say something like
this is the craziest thing i've ever
done i will double your safe galaxy
wallet
this tweet has now been deleted but i
pulled it up in the archives and then
they pick
some winners you won just confirming
this is the right address
maybe you see where this is going let's
go
here's my wallet address this is all we
need
using this wallet we simply cross check
it at the time of giveaway see that they
got the winnings and then check
who sent it we then check if that
address has saved the kids tokens
and other tokens that these people have
promoted in the past if it's actually
phase k's wallet
it should have both safe galaxy which
he's promoting here
and save the kids tokens which he also
promotes and it does
here's the save the kids tokens and
here's the safe galaxy tokens which
incidentally
he got from the safe galaxy deployer
meaning he's not just some random person
he's
clearly someone with influence that's
how these tokens do it they give
free tokens to the influencers from the
deployer wallet that's all there is to
it
ladies and gentlemen we got them
i just repeated that process for each
influencer and i found three
confirmed wallets phase k phase jarvis
and phase
nikken the others remain a mystery but
you know what this means
it means now that we have their wallet
address which is public we just didn't
know
whose public wallet address was theirs
now that we have that we can see
what they did with their save the kids
tokens we can check
all their so-called crypto endorsements
that they've been doing
and find out do they actually endorse
these products or do they dump them
immediately on you
so before i show you what they did just
remember these guys these influencers
leading up to this token being launched
promotional tweets are
sent out you know a damn commercial was
being made and remember it's all to save
the kids right
we're doing this not for money but to
save
the kids this is faze jarvis's wallet
he got in the pre-sale and quickly sold
out two-thirds
of his total holdings within days of the
launch
this is phase nikken he immediately sold
about a third of his total holdings
and then seems to have held on to the
rest but by far
the really bad one was faze k's wallet
he dumped all of his kids tokens
immediately within 24 hours he went from
6.2
billion tokens to four tokens now that's
right
he sold all but four tokens but
obviously
what's interesting here is that not all
of these influencers
acted quite the same way you know faze
nikan sold a third right away held under
the rest faze jarvis sold two thirds
over a few days
but phase k completely abandoned the
project altogether
why well i think it has to do with their
intentions look i
i looked pretty extensively over faze
nikan and jarvis's wallet history
they do not in my opinion have a pattern
of malicious selling what i mean by that
is when they get a coin
you know maybe they'll get some coins
sell some
buy some and you know sell some more
hold on to something
like a trader would and of course i'm
not saying that promoting garbage scam
coins to your fans is okay right it's
not but
everything they're doing it seems like
they're not pre-meditating
to sell everything phase k on the other
hand whose wallet we're looking at now
should be called faze rug actually what
i mean by that
is that he not only sold save the kids
instantly
he has a history of doing that to every
project or nearly every project
he gets involved in like take this coin
right here which is called
gamesafe.io he got these coins
immediately sold them out
and this is the date okay so 31 days ago
and then you could see the sell-off was
almost immediate or take another coin
safe galaxy which he's actually promoted
to his fans
he got coins from a deployer wallet once
again
and immediately sells them off now why
did he get these free tokens in the
first place well it was probably
his promotional tweets he did about them
to get safe galaxy follow this guide
remember to tweet safe galaxy
with your wallets i'm in the telegram
group chatting right now
ask me your questions there so he's
promoting this coin
to his followers telling them how great
it is meanwhile
his actual actions within his wallet
that we can see right here
again this is the same wallet that we
saw him sell the safety the kids often
eclipse
he's just selling everything as fast as
humanly possible
moon portal same thing what i'm trying
to say is this is a
pattern of deceiving his fans pumping
something
and selling it to his fans so he gets
the best price
how much money did he make from it we'll
try to calculate that later
and by the way if it feels like i'm
belaboring this point i am
phase k has consistently deceived his
audience
by pushing crypto to them while having a
bag of crypto given to him by these
coins i guess for promotions
and selling it immediately to them and
he'll make videos
promoting these tokens like moon your
moon
portal
is out right now guys you can swipe up
and check it out
he'll also tweet about them like this he
said wow
moon portal dot io making the robin hood
of crypto
great project and great team behind it
i'm with them
long term a hundred hmm that's
that's interesting really with them long
term 100
luckily we can check your wallet to see
what you
actually did it looks like you received
the funds
37 days and 18 hours ago or on may 22nd
and it looks like you
sold the coin also on may 22nd
so it looks like phase k you may not
understand
what long term quite means
either that or you're lying to your fans
which is it do you not know
what long-term 100 means or are you
blatantly
lying to your fans this man has
zero portal on him he had 43 billion
now he has zero and look why am i
showing you this well a few reasons
number one
while covering this some people put out
a theory
that save the kids failed because of a
tweet
from nelk that went out so they're
promoting it they're telling people that
they're ambassadors or whatever
the coin comes out it starts going up in
value
and then nelk puts out this pose and
after that tweet comes out from nelk
everybody starts panic selling and the
save the kids coin
plummets down and everyone loses their
money okay so the idea here is that it's
all
of nelk's fault for calling out these
influencers for what they're doing and
it caused this big panic cell it sounds
interesting but it
it's completely false and i want to
debunk this because i think this was
likely told to keemstar
to just make these influencers seem like
they're innocent but
it's false i know this because we can
actually see
when the tweet went out 7 55 june 5th
and phase k actually started selling
before that tweet
as you can see here he first started
selling june 5th as well
but this is utc time and adjusting for
that he started selling at 605
which is about two hours before nelk
would tweet now this proves that some
people involved
like face k and others planned to sell
from the start and even without the
simple proof by the way we know that he
would have sold anywhere from the start
because phase k
always sells from the start that's what
he does with almost all the coins he's
promoted before this now the second
reason i'm showing you all this evidence
is because i absolutely refuse to let
anyone spin this into a narrative
of like phase k being naive with crypto
not understanding what he was doing
right he he's innocent
you know just look at his apology i want
you all to know that i had no ill intent
promoting any crypto altcoins i honestly
and naively thought
that we all had a chance to win which
just isn't the case
he was naive guys this is yet another
lie
because if you thought everyone had a
chance to win you wouldn't be running
for the exit like someone just shouted
fire in these coins right
face k knew he had to be the first one
to get out of these coins in order to
profit
like he's done so many times before he
sold out of save the kids token
that he was an ambassador of within 24
hours
now i wish i could tell you who else
sold and what else they did because i'm
sure the others aren't completely
innocent but for now
a lot of these wallets remain a mystery
but now that we know
how these influencers you know spent
these coins when they sold them
i wanted to count up how much you can
make from a red pool like this
right that was one of our big questions
so i called up my buddy some ordinary
gamers
to help me calculate how much someone
like phase k stands to make
from these crypto promotions we crunch
the numbers by counting
how many tokens he sold times the price
at that time
and we got a rough estimate of how much
you stand to make
so really really rough estimate when you
look at the point of sale
around the sixth when the actual thing
was going on the peak of it
i think each calculation ended up being
around twenty nine thousand
thirty thousand for being a little bit
more liberal on that
but uh yeah it's about what we saw for
save the kids now of course when you
factor in all the other rock pulls
uh some of them went as high as like 40
50 60 000
right depending on the severity of that
pole so
cumulatively if you look at some wallets
some people who are you know
alleged to be behind multiple accounts
yeah that's a lot of money
i mean were you surprised i felt like it
wasn't as much as maybe i thought
that i thought surely they're not
risking their reputation
for something that's you know for an
influencer as big as they are
doesn't seem to be like insane yeah i
mean
i you got to imagine for people who have
entire personalities built around
mansions and supercars right
you're really risking your peak your
your
your great career on 30 000 which is a
lot of money but it's certainly not
enough to
warrant putting that much risk on you
you know what do you think is going to
happen at these guys
i mean if the sec wants to investigate
they're going to get they're gonna get a
fine maybe
maybe prison down lower outline i mean
the government doesn't screw around when
it comes to financial crimes
that's that that i think we know there
you have it somewhere in the range of
tens of thousands of dollars per
crypto coin that was rugged sometimes
more sometimes less but at this point i
have to tell you
that phase k completely denies profiting
from save the kids token
i reached out to him in preparation for
this video and he said
the following quote overall the value of
the token i purchased is down
considerably from my purchase price i
definitely
have not profited from save the kids
token
he also said he paid for some of the
expenses quote
i helped pay for the exchange listing or
whatever could help it
the purpose of the project is charitable
giving it's in that spirit and with that
intent that i was involved and i put
capital into it
hmm i don't know if i buy this like okay
let's just say you lost money on this
token i disagree that selling the coins
that you own within 24 hours
of a charity coin is in the spirit of
charitable giving
like you say also there's the small
matter of all these other tokens which
he failed to comment on but even the
fact he was able to sell all his tokens
in 24 hours
brings up sort of an interesting
question whatever happened to the
anti-whale mechanism
remember wasn't it supposed to prevent
people from selling off this quick
i mean you were only supposed to sell 20
within 24 hours so
what happened how was he able to sell
off this fast i started to wonder about
this and that's when i got a telegram
from someone
inside the project who messaged me
anonymously
hey coffee i remember something lucas
the developer told us before
the launch that the owners asked him to
modify
the anti-whale system from 24 hours to a
minute
so they were a hundred percent planning
to dump on everyone
if that's true that's the smoking gun
right there
it turns this project from a charity
coin with some bad actors that sold off
right away
into a pre-meditated fraud it turns it
from an
accidental rug pool into an intentional
one
so obviously i immediately started
looking through the code because this
guy
said he heard about it but he didn't
know where to find it and so i get to
digging
back to the lab again boys i can't
overstate
how much time i wasted looking for this
stuff and yes
it turns out that lucas the developer
had created
multiple test coins before launching the
main one in particular interest was
save the kids test 2 and the real save
the kids token
i compared their contracts using bsc
scan
and there was a single change in the
code
the old code of save the kids test 2
read that you must wait a full 24 hours
before you sell again
the new code which changed at the last
minute changed this anti-whale
to one minute you must wait a minute
before you sell it again
and this is the only change they changed
the token
just so they could pre-meditate this
whole thing
and almost remove the anti-whale
mechanism completely
they turned it from being a code that
wouldn't let whales sell off
in less than five days into a code that
lets you sell off
in five minutes again five days
they changed it to five minutes right
before launch
so obviously i start trying to reach out
to lucas because
this is what he seems to have kept for
me right like he acted innocent
initially he didn't tell me about any of
this but this shows that at least
he was a part of this right he was
complicit in this
finally i managed to get him into a
discord call where i confronted him
i'm seeing things from you that are
deeply uh
troubling in the code and you went awol
on me as soon as i
talked to you about this tokenomics
gmail.com not existing
i didn't see you saying that economics
and gmail.com
does exist no no not on paypal though
you said you got paid 10k at paypal
and we we forgot passworded it and it
doesn't 10k
and no i got 10k and b and b like i
that's what i was given from the token
directly
oh you said you said in the discord no
the paypal is from red
bubble i believe but i don't have that
then i asked him about this
anti-whale change lucas you
hard-coded it so what i mean by you
hard-coded in this thing to be a scam
is that i know that you change the
anti-whale measures last minute to make
it easier
to dump on people yeah yeah i know i've
talked about that in the
like in all the amas that's that's a
scam lucas that's a scam
coffee this is what i was told to do i'm
contracted i i don't know what to tell
you this is exactly what i was told to
do
i also asked him if he doesn't know the
creator of this project how did he even
get involved in the first place this
random guy named manny reached out to
him and he believed him
very coincidental that you would just be
like picked out of like a rabbit out of
a hat and you're so close
and you have no association i get that
okay
so you have no there's no explanation i
don't know they're randomly picked out
of the hat this was a huge surprise to
me wait oh
i remember when here um i was
talking to manny and he said that we're
gonna have influencers
on this project i think i can find this
picture actually and i was like you're
gonna have influencers on this project
he's like yep and he started naming
names uh and one of them was k
and i was saying i don't i'm sorry but
like obviously i don't believe you
he told me no actually he required proof
and this is what it was this was me
being proven that this was actually
influencers weren't bored on this
and i was like oh okay obviously i would
work for somebody like that like i don't
want to work for a project where there's
like
people behind that's crazy it's gonna be
huge if i had i guess my argument would
be if i had direct connections
then i wouldn't have to be sent a
picture like this that was like to prove
to me
so i guess that is what i'm trying to
show it says lucas
and man lucas and manny on this
to your mind does this mean that frasier
was in on this from the get-go like even
on the premeditation of this app
because it doesn't seem like he was
brought in as an afterthought
it seems like he was in this from the
beginning i assume all the influencers
probably were in this from the beginning
because those were already lined up like
straight off the bat wow
so phase k was in it from the beginning
now i confronted phase k on this and
asked him
how he knew manny and who manny was he
denied knowing him
he said i believe he is a friend of the
dev
or a dev i'm not sure exactly who he
really
is now that's funny because the dev says
he doesn't know manny at
all manny knew face k and phase k took a
picture
with the guy's name on it so i find this
pretty hard to believe you don't know a
guy and then you're writing his name
on paper i also asked lucas who is
behind
the anti-whale change obviously this is
one of the most malicious parts
of all the code he told me it was sort
of talked about in a group
of a lot of influencers it was a huge
group chat which he was later kicked out
of talking about the anti-whale thing
do you remember which influencers were
telling you that you need to basically
speed up
the time that they can just basically
dump more of their only remember because
he's on my screen i know smith was in
the group chat i don't know if he was
one of the main ones who was like
actually messaging it but i know there
was a general consensus of them being
concerned so they weren't the ones
telling me to lower it
they were very concerned with and i was
just trying to explain this is good for
the product
like blah blah like 24 hours good why do
you think they were concerned about that
well i mean obviously now probably
because they want to dump right away
another interesting moment of the call
was he told me that a youtuber named
joel morris was also involved now joel
morris is the creator of
xcademy token he's another one of these
guys claiming to be serious and
trustworthy with crypto
so what did this guy do when he got in
the pre-sale
phil morris was involved as well do you
remember what uh
address he gave you he should have given
you an address to like check
right uh yep can i see it i
have it let's do a quick
check here easy skin all right
oh he immediately dumped oh
man he looks like he took joel morris
took
advantage of your little crypto
rule here four hours everything right
away
and then within it looks like yep
yep within a very short amount of time
he completely dumped his bags
he sold immediately to drive the price
of a kid's
charity token even further into the dirt
by the way you'll notice here that joel
morris took advantage
of the change in the anti-whale code
because he was
selling literally every minute so
clearly
these influencers knew that the code has
changed now
honestly this whole thing is so vomit
inducing
like this developer's telling me he was
misunderstood and is just following
orders you have face k
saying he didn't make money despite
trying his hardest to be the first to
sell
off you've got basically everyone
claiming to be innocent but you couldn't
design
a bigger token scam and a bigger
commercial for it the biggest
influencers in the world all saying that
it's such a great opportunity
now the last person we need to talk
about is sam pepper
this is an old youtuber who according to
reddit posts
now works with faze apparently he's
their camera guy
or comes up with video ideas or
something the point is he's
close by them he talks to them etc he
kept coming up in my investigation
even though he wasn't a public part of
the project he apparently was one of the
people
promoting this thing on reddit and
creating the mod team i was told as much
by the mods themselves the biggest thing
that that i know
is that typo who was a mod asked me to
be a mod before launch
i know that him and some of his guys
were brought in
by pepper to mod this stuff up hmm
so pepper was brought in to mod this
thing up
so what does sam know how is he involved
and how much did he really organize a
different mod
reached out from the group and told me
that the group had been talking and
realized that maybe sam
was the common link they said in a
conversation that
sam handled the pre-sale as far as i
know
and that quote sam deleted his telegram
why did he do that
i had someone actually reach out to sam
and he said
that he also had no idea who manny was
he seemed to be in charge of finding the
mod team
and says that he's not the mastermind
after all
phase k apparently brought him on board
quote that makes no sense how would i
already be
on board if i found out from k about the
project
when i found out about it from k he was
already an ambassador
wait so phase k got sam
pepper in the coin which was later
confirmed by
phase k himself he said they asked me if
i have chat mods but i don't
i knew sam had mods so i asked for his
not for sam
himself now bear in mind sam pepper
doesn't have a
a great reputation around crypto he's
known as scam pepper
by some of the cryptocurrency community
for all of the the rug pools that he
promotes himself
but nevertheless it's all leading back
to phase k who himself is insisting that
oh no i didn't make any money
that he's the victim in all of this so
where does that
leave us fact one we know phase k
lied about being some naive crypto
investor he's got a history
of dumping nearly every crypto project
he's ever been involved in
and promoting it to his fans fact two we
know this thing was designed from the
absolute get-go to be a scam you bring
people in
with this anti-whale mechanism and then
at the last minute
you remove it number three we know a lot
of other youtubers were involved
even besides the ambassadors themselves
people like
joel morris who sold off immediately in
fact
four we know that the real victims were
you the fans of these guys who got in
believing that you were somehow
supporting
kids by getting involved that's the
biggest lie of this whole project that
kids were gonna be helped by this the
only thing
we really don't know at this point is
who the creator
and mastermind of this entire operation
was
i have my suspicions but no proof
whoever they are though
they successfully used the greed of
influencers and their following
to design one of the grossest rug pools
of
all time that used charity to
take money from fans who are less
well-off
and give it to the people who were
shilling the thing i guess and it's not
for trying that we don't know who that
is i've asked
everyone involved lucas i've asked all
the influencers i've been in contact
with
everyone claims to not know who this
mastermind
is is it this manny guy i also heard of
a character named
h in the telegram who apparently was
ordering everyone around
they all say they have no idea who these
guys are and that's
either yet another lie or these
influencers are just
really dumb and didn't bother to do due
diligence
on the project that they were about to
promote to their millions of fans
all right well that basically uh
concludes my investigation i i hope the
people
involved with this face justice for it
and i also hope that
two parties learned from this one you
the viewers should now be sufficiently
disgusted by the actions of these
so-called
influencers the second group that should
learn from this are influencers
if you are an influencer let me tell you
from the bottom of my heart
stop it get some help if you don't the
feds are gonna
eventually stop you anyways what was
done
here today with this token could be
considered illegal
john mcafee literally got charged doing
the same things
you guys did and the fact that you're
throwing away your name and brand for
this
is disgusting stop posting on social
media about crypto
period if you're not a financial advisor
stop acting like a financial advisor
and that's it i tried to tell you guys
it was going to be a crazy one but
man even i didn't realize how long this
thing was gonna be
now i can finally rest stop covering
these stupid influencer scams
you know and just really just relax
hello there that's justin bieber
i'm perez hilton and if you like
dogecoin
you'll love baby dogecoin oh
god no i'm doing the same thing as you
holding my doink that's what i'm doing
this is a
coin
[Music]
wake up and smell the coffee
[Music]